hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge mein
klavier sitzt wahrscheinlich schon im
titel eingeblendet und zwar video ohne
fans kämen deswegen ist das hier ein
video mit face käm ich sag vorher mal
kurz ein paar worte was ich mir dabei
gedacht hat und zwar denke ich mir jeden
freitag irgendwas okay was könnte ich in
minecraft machen kündigen command
vorstellen könnte ich in pvp zocken
irgendwann aber es muss er vielleicht
mal ein bisschen hat sein was ich noch
nicht so gemacht habe deswegen hab ich
jetzt gedacht ich teste diesmal einfach
dass ich so eine stumpfe runde survival
games ohne face kämpfe so wie ich es
quasi damals vor drei jahren gemacht
habe oder von vier jahren
dann habe ich mit vor fünf jahren ich
weiß es gab gar nicht mehr so genau
jedenfalls hab ich halt damals so
minecraft pvp gebracht und dann so keine
ahnung survival games ohne facetime und
einfach nur gezockt und ich war trotzdem
scheiße und das wird für mich total
schwierig sein weil ich ja voll oft für
euch so interagieren über diese face cam
und die ist jetzt einfach jetzt ist die
fans kam einfach weg alter faktisch
schätzt ich lasse die face kann man sich
einfach mal weiter laufen also für mich
leute die gerade rechts noch weil ich
die am ende des videos wieder ein blende
und wir zogen jetzt erst mal eine runde
survival games haben hier direkt und
einen herr merz ist hier irgendwie war
auch du heilige schein kiste und scherzt
wir jetzt tatsächlich noch ne kiste mit
einem stein schwer doch ich werde nicht
mehr freunde das kann nur geil werden
ich merke jetzt schon wieder das ist für
mich nie ein orkan die was bringt diese
verfügte auto ist ein spieler über ihr
vermögen verfügte blödmann als small
denkt glaube ich jetzt ich bin auf
kanada nach peking bastarde klinik mit
einer blöden angel oder fakt er schadet
mir euch wer nicht mehr
es fällt mir sowas auch fakt jetzt bin
ich hier natürlich auch auf dem was
fühlt sich das schnell es fällt mir so
schwer das ganze zu kommentieren also
ich kann es gar nicht mehr ich muss den
ball sonst immer wenn ich dann weiß okay
da ich halt die fresse da gucke ich halt
schnell in die 4
kämmerer locator ist das nicht eine cod
map die wir hier gar zocken dann weiß
ich so jung interagiert jetzt irgendwie
mit euch und frage euch irgendwie
wandten schals oder indirekt schon los
barbara ich glaub ich werd das ganze
video nur darüber rummeckern wie blöd
diese idee war das ganze unter fans
games machen weil ich total
eingeschränkt bin was das schneiden
angeht weil ich hab voll oft einfach
nicht face kamran summe oder dann mal
was anderes machen oder es ist schon
wieder eine cd the water krieg ist es
neid ich habe hier eine hose ich habe
hier so ein ding ich habe schon ein
schwert und die da hinten boxen sich
schon tot rief werth ja nicht mehr hague
ich boxe ich und du kannst mir nichts
weil ich boxe dich und du kannst mir
nicht und ich war bei gott ich aber
entgelt man hier langlaufen und jetzt
bin ich hier was mache ich jetzt hier
ich habe einstein schwert und macht
jetzt einen dropkick auf den nennt man
das dropkick ich weiß es nicht ich gehe
jetzt auf irgendwen drauf wenn ich
jemanden finde hier irgendwo vielleicht
versteckt sich hier irgendwo ein mensch
der denkt okay war luca den kann ich auf
jeden fall das ist ohne hose hier kann
ich mich tatsächlich nochmal meine cod
zeit erinnern ich stand immer hier und
habe auf die anderen da hinten
gesundheit und hab es aber irgendwie nie
hingekriegt kann ich nicht irgendwie
jetzt so combo mäßig und so einen
geschützten raum ein fucking gott wieso
bin ich darin wie viele leben dennoch es
leben noch fünf spieler und ich muss
jetzt hier einfach mal vielleicht hat 14
tage glaube ich an alle die es in den
kommentaren wiederum helden wie schlecht
ich denn sei ja ich gedacht und
vielleicht tatsächlich dass ich mich
irgendwie verbessere wenn ich meine fans
kann nicht anders und ich mich dann mehr
auf das spiel konzentrieren das war aber
ein kompletter griff ins klo irgendwie
in die kiste hole ich mir da die
und dann direkt einstein schwert und
jetzt ist der typ da hinten der wird
jetzt erst mal tatsächlich wo ist er hin
ich bin was ist das da sehen wir wieder
wie toll ich in diesem spiel bin
tatsächlich ich hab mir halt tatsächlich
gedacht dass ich vielleicht irgendwie
besser werde wenn ich auf 20 punkte
ich hab doch mal poker jagd jemand
retten
und ja ich habe mir wirklich eingebildet
dass ich vielleicht höre scores
erreichen könnte wenn ich einfach ok ok
ok ok sachen anziehen jetzt verweise ich
habe kein wasser faktors bis zu
gefährlich von dem blöden schiff dabei
gehen ich habe hier drin ein schwert das
ist doch schon mal eine schöne nachricht
tatsächlich sind hier viele kisten
überall ich habe ich freiwillig habe ich
habe keine feinde und kann ich irgendwie
kann ich hier irgendwie kann ich ihn da
hinten an
nein das kann ich kann ich mit fisch an
ich hab nur fleisch mm kann vielleicht
der willicher runterschubsen der
blödmann
ich dachte er will mit mir zusammen
fischen aber ich glaube die sind nicht
so nette menschen
die fans cup ist jetzt wieder an nicht
okay es geht schon wieder los nur damit
ihr mal seht ihr was ist der unterschied
ist mit der fälschung expression oder
wie man das auch immer nennen damit
nicht einfach zeigen kann wie ich mich
fühle
ich werde an dieser stelle das video
beendeten auflief bin jetzt wieder hier
in der lobby das war jetzt mal so ein
test wie ich kommentieren würde oder
schneiden würde wenn ich keine face kann
hätte und ich glaube es war tatsächlich
hart langweilig ich wollte für mich
selber einfach mal als test sehen auch
um mal jetzt gleich in die wenn ich ein
video hochgeladen habe in die youtube
analytics rein zu schauen um zu schauen
wie lange die leute so dran waren das
wird ja mittlerweile alles getrackt so
der und der ist so lange dran geblieben
und der und der hat das und das
interessiert mich mal selber irgendwie
wie das irgendwie wie lang man dran
bleibt wenn man nicht das gesicht von
einem youtuber sieht und keine ahnung
sagt willi social experiment das hört
sich viel zu intellektuellen dafür um so
etwas zu machen
vielleicht hat euch gefallen vielleicht
sagen ein paar ja das ist richtig cool
macht das noch mal und ich denke dass
alle sagen werden
das macht gar keinen sinn aber sonst
würde ich mich auf jeden fall meine
bewertungen freuen und ich bin halt in
new york wenn ihr das video gerade sehen